إنها المرة الأولى التي أكون فيها في دبي ،
ويسعدني أن أكون هنا لأنني أشعر
أنها واحدة من تلك الهوامش التي
تتفهم حقًا الماكياج وتحبه وأيضًا
لاستخدامه وأكثر من ذلك ، وأرى امرأة
تضع رموش ظلال العيون.  وكأنهم
يفعلون كل شيء وأنا أحب آه ،
هذا رائع جدًا ، إنه أشبه بالمكياج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العمل بجمال خيالي و
التورط في علامة تجارية صدمت من
أن صناعة التجميل هي
طريقة جذرية ورؤية الناس
يأتون إلي ويقولون ، أعتقد أن لدي أخيرًا
أساس ما نفعله كل هذه السنوات
قبل التخيل ، نحن لا نؤمن بالقواعد التي
نقوم بها  لا أحد يجب أن ترتدي
هذا اللون ويجب أن تدرك
أننا نؤمن بأن أي جنس وأي عرق وأي
ثقافة يمكن لأي شخص أن يرتديها العمل
مع Fionna كان حقًا أحد تلك
الأشياء حيث يكون مثل حلم لا نهاية له
عندما تكون مثله.  يجب أن أستيقظ
هذه كذبة لأنها
خارجة  موهوبة للغاية كفنانة مكياج
وليست موسيقي ، فهي منخرطة جدًا عندما
يتعلق الأمر بمظهر الشرف الذي
ابتكرته وجهًا فاخرًا وهو مظهرنا المميز
للعلامة التجارية
[موسيقى]
وما تؤمنين به وبفضل ذلك يمكنك
رؤية ذلك إذا كنت  أشعر بالرضا فيه
ويجعلك تشعرين بالثقة
والمثيرة والقوية يمكن لمكياج تريكسي إذا
كنت ترغبين في خلعه جربي شيئًا
آخر